Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Blank Dream
It's finally back!
It's finally here!
After nearly a year of
being missing in action, Blank Dream is gonna be finished
in this episode. Now,
I am very sorry that it took so long
I have no other excuse besides my own laziness at this point.
And, um, the reason it fell out initially was
obviously because this, uh, the last episode
came out just like a week or two before Daniel died
and so that threw a wrench in everything
including all my plans
Um, and also! I was using a different computer for a while there
So I didn't have the computer that had this save file on it
and I just didn't have the motivation to go back and play through it all again
BUT! This is the same save file that I had before
It's the same game, we're picking it up
I actually had to go back and re-watch
the final episode of the game
to know where we left off and what happened
but Mishiro here  (silence) that's her name right?
Is that not her name?
Is that her?
Yeah Mishiro! Mishiro here
has some things, and she's ready
to get going on her adventure because we just came out of the school
and we just got through recovering another piece of her memory
So, we need to find out what THIS is
This mystery has been burning in our brains for the past...many many months
(silence)
OH! A gold key!
Did I pick that up before? I'm not a hundred percent sure
But either way,
time to skedaddle on out of here!
Hel--
(Mark falls into a sudden silence)
*beep beep beep beep*
AH FUCK!
OHHH! FUCKING--
I FORGOT ABOUT YOU!!
I THOUGHT I WAS OUT OF THE SCHOOL!
Hoooooly SHIT!
(silence)
HI!
"The Sixth Mystery is the Forgotten Classroom. There's a room with an entrance that can't be seen."
"I've heard it's somewhere around the bathrooms but I--" *stutters*
I've already done the mystery things!
I've already done all of that! Do I just need to go home?
I just completely forgot
euhh
Aww, dammit!
ughhh
I kinda forgot about everything over here
aw, it's been so long but I th--
--I think I'm done!
Hi!
Awwwh! It's been so long!
"You're remembering who you are, bit by bit?"
"Get back our memories, grant our wish. What'll happen to the deceased after that?"
"Surely we'll (*splutters*) be at peace and go to heaven?!"
Yeaaah, I'm not a hundred percent sure about that...
"Deep in the realms, huh? I've always stayed away because all the evil spirits."
"Does that stuff not bother you, Mishiro?
OF COURSE IT BOTHERS ME!!
THEY TRIED TO NIBBLE ON MY GIBLETS!
I BARELY GOT AWAY WITH MY LIFE!
But I'm gonna get through this because I'm braaave or something...
Not a hundred percent sure about that. Okay
"It seems unopenable."
So, I have a gold key...
Now, that unlocks the gold dooooors...
The Realm of Blood...?
"Bathe in it if you wish, and go mad"
Well!
I got a gold key!
So let's go...bathe in the madness, why don't we?!
Alright
What'd ya got for me?
oooooh
Is that a bunch of statues?
What is that moving?
whazit?
euh!
I don't like the sound of this!
"We shall guide you to the mirror quickly and without interruption"
Oh!
"Welcome, Master, to the Realm of Blood"
*Scoffs* Thank you!
It's about damn time I got the respect I deserved!
Woahkay...
"An angel-like statue--"
"--polished to a shine"
I imagine they're all the same...
Oh PRESENTS?!
Ohohoa! MAN!
They sure know how to...
(...?)
...welcome someone!
I bet it's not gonna all be like this
Okay...
"For now, give no thought to the return trip"
Okay, why? What happens if I--
Uh-oh
*nervously* Oh, the door's gone!
Well that's good
"If you are tired, enjoy a soothing meal"...?
WOAHOAHOH!
Don't mind if (*pause*) I do!
Non-alcoholic wine? Well, where's the fun in that?
(*muttering*) I guess I can drink it...
"Tea on the table; just the right temperature..."
I can't sit in the chair though.
Oh, okay
...That don't look good!
Hello?
(*slightly louder*) Hello?
(*demanding attention*) Hello??
(*Markiplier raising his voice more*) HELLO?
HELLO?!
Uughguhghhhh???
What's that...?
Uh-oh!
OH!
OKAY?!
How and why and what--
do...?
I'm beginning to think I understand why I might go mad here...
So don't go in THAT door!
That door is the BAD door!
Ah! Good
"If you see anything you like, relax at your leisuuuuure."
Okay.
"A pretty, white dress"
Can I put it on?
"A beautiful painting"
(*To the painting*) Can I put it on?
"A piano. Mishiro can't play"
(*To the piano*) Can I wear it like a dress?
"A table with a vase"
"A large clock; age is evidennnnnt"...
Hhhhheeyyyyyyy...
No need to do that!
Eugh
Many books...
Stuff like that...
Psychology...
Whadaboutover-
[frustration] God dammit, it's another one of these!
Is it just immediately down?
Yeaaaahhh, it immediately is.
Well god dammit, what's the point of all that?!
It's gonna loop for ever and ever!
I gotta get back down ta where I was before
Eventually, I'm gonna be able to get through that,
but I imagine I need some sort of item to get myself through...
I don't have the wherewithal to do it alone
"If you wish you may take a comforting rest"
"The mirror is to your left"
Ooah
"The teddy bear stares with round eyes"
"cute"
Shhuure it is
"Large canopy, Soft enough for your body to sink into"
EEH
So that probably goes back to the other place again, the looping hallway...
So I'm gonna trust em!
Here we go!
*constipated* I've full trustingness doing the thing the trust, oh boy
Okay? OH WHY'S THERE SO MUCH BLOOD?
Oh that's not a good sign.
"Mirror shows.." alright look in!
"has a bad feeling, unlike any before!"
Yeah why not?
[unsure laughing] Let's go for it
We're gonna bathe in blood and go mad!
Oeuhghh *sigh* kay
What do we got?
Hiiii
My name's Mashiro!
"Hey Usui you're late"
"Because I had gym"
"I don't care! Just give us our homework!"
"You didn't do it did
you?"
Oh, okay
Yes boss
"Can't get in the mood for three math worksheets, thanks '𝑙𝑖𝑡𝑡𝑙𝑒 U𝑠𝑢𝑖';
"A thousand yen fee for every wrong answer- You're rich so that's enough responsibility."
Mashiro: "What am I doing? I'm living like a slave to every whim of these pieces of garbage"
Bullies: "You listenin' Usui?! Always spacing out, that 'Blank-stares' Usui alright!"
"Does the class even know you're a student? -
If you don't stand out some nobody's gonna notice ya!"
Mashiro: I've been dealing with them for about three months
They're just letting out stress for the coming exams
They're not going to a decent high school anyway...
That's the sort of thing I think about
as I let it wash over me
and endure...
With the recent death of my grandpa, a famous artist,
The Usui family has been in turmoil over his inheritance.
So I can't talk to my parents
Or stop attending school. At home, I care for my family:
At school, for these losers.
I feel myself withering, lonely and doubting.
What am I living for?
...I'm the one who's building up loads of stress, not you jerks.
Bullies: "Say did you know, 𝐼 𝑑𝑜𝑜𝑜-contrary to appearances she really likes frilly outfits."
"...Ueh!..."
"Huh? for real?!"
"Totally?"
"Like gothic lolita and stuff?!"
"She's gone out like that on her days off!"
Now that's something, 𝑆𝑜𝑜𝑜𝑜 Cute 𝑈𝑠𝑢𝑖. You wanna be a 𝑃𝑟𝑖𝑖𝑖𝑛𝑐𝑒𝑠𝑠?"
...Don't talk about people's tastes like that you...
COCKSUCKERS! I dunno
*reading onscreen text*
I didn't know Wario walked in
F-F-F-F Fuuuuuuck you-u
*reading onscreen text*
COCKSUCKERS SOMethIng something...
Ooh jeez
Ah.
Oh did I? -- Woah no
OOooh
*onscreen text*
WWHYYY?!!
This poor girl!!
She was defending herself, that's clear to anybody!
Outnumbered, it doesn't matter, aeugh
*reading onscreen text*
Aghh...
Idonknew..-- Not- Not yet.
*evil laughing* I can kill them and
leave no survivors
WAHAHAUHAHUAHUAHH!!!!
*raspy inhale*
*on-screen text*
(high pitched and maniacally) WAUahh you better run!
Ahm coming for youu~
Wah. Woah. Woh.
You think you can get away from me? HA?!
Woah I GOT YEH!
Woh woh woh WOOOOOAAAHH
YE BETTER RUNN
Wohaohh, WEEHOOAAHHH!!
Woohooahooooahh! Markimoo's coming to getcha!
oh geez
uhoh
oh jeez
WELP
ONE DOWN... ooh that's morbid...
woh... hey.
Stop it!
Ohohohoh noo
ooh no
Oooohhh hohoho
Wooh, suddenly it's... less fun than I thought it'd be...
Weogh
Woauhgh
eH EUghU EGHH
EUGHhhh
*Let the evil giggling begin*
Wait-
"What... was it this simple?"
"Was it this pleasant? ...And it was it this sho (so) short-lived?"
"It feels like nothing matters anymore."
*ominous clang of music* HI
Oh.
"I am you, and you are me."
"Oh, poor me... You toe- too looked into the mirror and lost it."
"Looking into your memories can mean prying open the lid on past trauma."
"To think, a new ruler has arrived, and yet it just came to this..."
"So long. I can't hope for anything good to follow."
Oh. (*laughing*) "Ending 5: Mistakes Repeated".
"She, too! Was lost to mad-nass!"
Alright....
(*smacks lips*) Well, that's not the ending that we wanted,
so we gotta back and we gotta go through all the dialogue again and then choose the *other* option.
I mean, I don't think there's any other option to not look into this mirror but,
Cause if you go back, you're just gonna be lost in the waste, so the idea is that you don't stick around after all this happens, so...
I'll be right back!
Oh shit, did I do-? Oh, crap. Oh, ok!
I was taking a drink of water and spamming the space bar, but I guess I did the thing.
Ok, that's good.
At least we didn't go mad. That's an ah-
that's a good 'un. Alright.
"Mishiro came to, again standing before the mirror."
"Though she felt- still felt a vigorous feeling inside her hands, there was no trace of a knife wound."
"Yes. In the third term of my second year of middle school, I turned a knife on those delinquents."
"As a result, all my efforts to calm my parents as they dealt with the inheritance went to waste..."
"I set off a bomb just waiting to burst. My mother became hysterical and strict after that."
"She desperately tried to 'train me right.'"
"And so I lost a place to belong."
Well, I'm sorry about that.
Just as Mishiro regained a piece of her memory
She felt as if she'd lost something important
Iiiiis that ssooo? hm.
I don't- I still don't know what that means
Because that's been going on the entire time
That I've been playing the game. So it's like,
It's a bizarre thing; I wonder-
... what we're losing???
Oh sorry
thought that was something else...
Alright,
Well...
I guess I'll go back now
Still don't know
if there's anything to the north over here
Oohhhh there is, there is
now anyway, Hello!
Aaaah ha ha HA! *the knowing laugh of discovery*
We found somethin'!
Boy, looks bad
Euw..
I don't have a lantern, oh nope theresss whaaaat?
A second mi-rror?
"Mirror shows nothing; some requirements need to be met."
What do meeeeeean?
ooooo
dammit
So that's something else; I don't think I've
been to a realm where there's been two
mirrors before, thaaat is
bizzaaare...
So we need to meet the requirements
probably in the zone somewhere unless I can just leave...
I can just leave!
...well...
Huh... but
there is a secret mirror there
maybe something's unlocked later on
that I can go to
there before because I believe this is the
last door
before the main door down there, so maybe if I find something
in here I'll be able to go
Somewhere else
what realm was this again?
~𝐑𝐞𝐚𝐥𝐦 𝐨𝐟 𝐃𝐞𝐚𝐭𝐡~ '𝑁𝑜 𝑙𝑖𝑓𝑒 𝑐𝑎𝑛 𝑙𝑖𝑣𝑒-
Wait- 𝑏𝑒𝑓𝑜𝑟𝑒- Before what?
-𝑎 𝑑𝑖𝑠𝑡𝑜𝑟𝑡𝑒𝑑 𝑤h𝑒𝑒𝑙'
"A distorted wheel" That's what I thought it said!
But I didn't- Oh.
eup. Oh no...
*Glass breaking* AH! FFFUCK OFF!
*sighs heavily, catching breath*
*breathes heavily*
*muttering* Where are the other guys going...
Ohh
oh. Hi.
Hello.Hi
friend! whoooo the fuck are
you?
*thick southern accent* "12/8 The Holy mother heard a divine
message from God"
*beep beep beep beep*
*enemy appears*AAAH! ohfuuuuck
Euuuaaaaaah!
Ok...So don't step
on the glass Goddamnit
fuck. "The room is dark, the weak lantern
doesn't seem able to light the room
adequately" Ok I'll just give up then
I gotta get a straaaa-Oh.
Ooh. Thought that was death.
"There's an unnatural gap in the books on the
in the books on the left of the middle"
How 'bout a knife?
No.... No.
How 'bout lantern-it's useless.
Hamm-ar? ok.
Hello! "The stone statue quietly looms"
Well I'll let you get back to your
loomin' big man
you stay, you stay 'loomy'
Ah-I love a loom "Respect your predecessors"
How 'bout no? Fuck 'em.
hmmm
that's not...that's not good.
Uh-oh
huh.
"It's nowhere...my-" Wut?
"Respect your predecessors"
So that's the first one
ok.
"It's nowhere...my-" If I go up here
Ok, so, still there but what if I go up
one more? No?
So...this level is different
It's got blood over here
Eh, "What do I ?"
I dunno!
Ww-I dunno! wurbrekur
yerbuhbababur,
Goddammit ok this is a puzz-lul
So I gotta get to the unique
places with the blood
probably trailing me to where I'm supposed
to go
oh. Wasn't there either, oh my.
Hello!
HI! What the hell happened?!
AAH! MY BRAIN!
WHY THE DEAD END!
WHY DID YOU BITE MY FRONTAL LOBE!
I need that...I think.
It's amazing what you can do without a frontal lobe
Continuing on, this time a little less stupidly
Ok so this one first,
And obviously don't go backwards
towards the giant pit of blooo
oood
ok... There's more blood
wait a minute, ah,
ok so that was different
ah so there's more blood over there now but maybe
if I go to the right
Is this gonna be?...dammit ok so
that's the same place as I was before and I'm deeefinitely
not supposed to follow the blood too much
cause that's bad for everybody
involved...what about down here?
Dammit, I'm all the way back
wow, ok. So this is, this is quite a loop
So I gotta base it off of
what do I? maybe straight
across?
Nope, that ain't it either.
And this is just gonna loop me back, right?
Yeah. Ok, so the only answer is going down here and THEN going across.
So, the other answer has to be going through one of these....
Damn it. Ok, so it's definitely not that one.
But, it- it does SEEM to me... that if you go up here, it DOES change.
"It wasn't here, either."
But. Aw, damn it.
Ah, getting bitten- eaten- bweh.
So, what does that mean?
So, I probably gotta go south first and get something that's gonna make me safe through there.
There's not much indication of what's going on, but I can only assume that I'm stupid and doing it wrong.
*laughs* Ok.
Fu- fuuuuck off! Fuck. Aw, god damn it.
Well! I forgot how douche-y this game could be in terms of kill-you, deathness. Well, ain't that sad. Ok.
"The Holy Mother's Most Beloved Day". Oh!
Yeah, I don't know. 12, 8, and her birthday. But when's her birthday?
"10/20, the king who ruled over the world came ta greet the Holy Mother."
Ok, so it wouldn't have been THAT day.
"...gave alms to the poor children." Maybe that day. 06/12.
Mother was born on 09/5? That-
(*singing*) AaaaaaaAAAAAAaaaaaooooooohhhhuuuuhh
Ok, nice- good thing that I got my operatic practice out of the way. Now I can actually do something.
But maybe not... Definitely not when someone visited her...
Definitely not... Ah, maybe this one. 12/08. That- that would be a good one. Ok, 06/12 might be it.
Aiiii! Yeah! So, it wasn't when she got the message; it was when she gave to the children.
Nyah-ha-ha! I am the smart! I am very smart!
"Full of junk and covered in dust." Just like my... life.
I was gonna make a sex joke, but I thought it wouldn't a been... (*whispers*) appropriate.
Ok, so can I light it with... Can I light it with the lantern?
No? Ok. Well, so what is this all about, then? There's nothing here. Did I check all the bookshelves?
Ah, here we go. Ok, matchbooks. Ok, so I got matches which means I should be able to light this.
Light IT UP! No, not that...
"Stab the knife into yourself?" How about NO. *laughs* I forgot that was an option.
Matches. Matches, matches, matches, matches! Oh, come on. So I need to find what, wood?
Maybe I could grab kindling from one of the other things. "Dilapidated shelves." "Full of junk."
Well, that doesn't help me at all! Affff- fucking fuck!
I wasn't ready for THAT!
I didn't think i was gonna be needed to call to action!
FUCK
FINE THEN!
oh shitballs
okay you go by
06/12
Lucky code of the day....
and then... I'm guessing I need to pop out then pop immediately back in
because.. it wasn't all- there wasn't anything else to do
to do about it
okay you got that
alright so I'm gonna go get the matches
Maybe the matches are what I need to light my way in the other area
okay
okay... so I got this
now immediately bac- HEYAYAY
oh - Jeez
That is terrifying
That is TERRIFYING
Why is that necessary??
okay
GOODBYE THEN!
Take luck!
Take luck and care!!
If you HAVE luck, take it, care for it!
alright, let's try this
save first, jeezums
good JEEZUM Golly Goosh!
Alright. How 'bout the matches?
God dammit. No matches?!?
Doesn't make any sense...
ERRRAAAUUGGH!!
What's with this puzzle?
I don't gggettt it!
I don't ggghhettt it!!
Okay, so something goes here...
What about the matches?
No?!?
Aw, I thought that was actually the sound of something happening.
It was just poorly timed.
Ok so.
It's nowhere..
my...
AAHHHHH! What about this?
Aww dammit, that wasn't it either. Okay so.
So, there's gotta be something to this besides just "The Death."
Of which what do I?? I don't know.
What do I?
Fuck.
Maybe I've just gotta go to the damaged ones. Maybe that's like a clue.
'Cuz there are damaged ones,
and if I continually go there....
*ominous boom boom noise*
OOOOOOHHHHHHHHH!! IT WAS TRUE!!
OKAY! AHH!! This bureau
"burrow" with an odd air about it has a blue..
book... I'll take that. Okay. (*aha music*)
"I timidly took it." Why can't I boldly the take it?
I want it so baydly.
Alright. Now that I'm finally solving things -
Not that.
*knock knock*
Blubchk
*jumpscare*
AWWRRR FUCK OFF WITH YOU!
GODDAMMIT!
FUCK YOU!
YA PIECE O SHIT!!
These monsters are testin' mah patience!
I shoulda gone insane!
I shoulda known he wouldn't like that very much.
But dat's okay.
Alright, so let me just do this.
Not that - that's not what I meant.
I need to go here.
Go through here.
Go up.
*thunk thunk thunk*
And then immediately back down.
And then we at da place, we get da thing.
And when we get da thing,
take it. (*aha music*)
Okay, so what we need to do is we need to get - put the book in place
and then immediately bolt the fuck out of there
but I'm gonna go save first because *chime*
Holy shit, this game loves to throw death at ya!
Here we go!
*Jumpscare*
Aughaa! (*high pitched screaming*) Oh - goddammit.
Don't do that!
Don't be angry about so much...
Take some aromatherapy ya beytch!
*THUNK*
(In high 'Mishiro' voice) OH NO! I AM TRAPPED!
Haha. I wonder what this switch does?
Huh, I bet it's totally gonna keep me nice -
*thunk*
-and alive
Takin these. Checked for traps and picked up the gold. (*aha music*)
Aright. So what about these spikes here?
Huh? (*splooshy sound of death*)
Erghh! (high pitched)
Oh God! (still high pitched)
I schtepped on 'em and died immediately!
That's how wimpy I am.
God dammit.
She's goddamned dead.
Okay. So we need to pull the lever.
Lever - okay, pull it - katchunk.
Got that. Lever down.
(German-ish Scottish-ish accent) Good. Good. Great!
The best! Okay what is you?
Old book. Take it.
Manual on using lamps. (*aha music*)
Oh!
What! You mean.. you mean I couldn't figure out the little itty bitty knob
right by the flame there *scoff* oh - too complicated!
Every single goddamned Cracker Barrel has a goddamned lamp like this!
Alright. I'm gonna adjust the... the FUCK out of this lamp.
Strengthen it!!
Yeah!!
Why would you not?
Oh. Maybe if you need to hide from something that might be...
"Mishiro Usui. Dead."
"Here lies Mishiro Usui."
"Mishiro Usui has died."
"Mishiro eyes will never open again."
That doesn't necessarily mean '𝑑𝑒𝑎𝑑'
"Mishiro Usui speaks no more."
Again,
Not quite dead!
Alright. Okay.
Alright - that's good.
Well, at least I- I was special enough to have 𝑓𝑖𝑣𝑒 gravestones.
That's lovely.
Okay. But either way I got a lantern now.
Dat means *chime*... that I goin ta go in here.
There we go.
Hello!
"Let West always be the opposite of East."
Okay - what about that?
It won't open
"Let West always be the opposite of East." Ok,
so what?
Uh huh. What did,
What did I do?
Oooohhh! It's one of those-
I know what it is, it's-it's aaa 'left right' situation
where
Haaah god
damn it of 𝑐𝑜𝑢𝑟𝑠𝑒 there's gonna be SOMETHING that's gonna
just bite my face off in there
goddammit, son of a crap.
Alright so it's one of those
left right mirror situations and we haven't,
weh-eh, we've seen it before but...
now we've gotta do it next but it's gotta
be the exact opposite all the time
ok so,
sword on the wall, a western
sword, ok.
everything looks
relativelyyy sim-ple
so what else would be changed here?
Ah, this stool was upside down
wait; less,leh-
'𝑊𝐸𝑆𝑇' always equal East
that means west has,
ah they just have to match
...wait, the opposite
or equal? wait, opposite or equal?
"Let West always be the opposite of East." aaaah Opposite
ok so these, these
need to be  flipped
ok so and then these need to be
switched, Ah! is that the only other
thing I can do?
I could open the closet but I don't know
is this gonna kill me?
so maybe, ugh, maybe, lemme try opening the other one
and then maybe I can make this one the
closet. No?
well it's the only thing I can
change
*groan*
*loud thunk sound*
Nope! goddammit fucking death
goddammit, shit
Ohhhh there we go, ok I got it now
it opened hooray!
I, I'm pretty sure I did all that before anyway
but "some things cannot be seen
while there is light"
eh really? huh really? so what if I
adjust my goddamn lantern
to the point where it's
weakened. ah ok
how 'bout that?
ah. oo.
"Stab the sword into the unseen corpse!"
that seems like a bad thing but,
okay.
no, don't do that.
'kay
" In the darkness, stab the sword into
the unseen corpse."
So here...
...th' swo'
I don't haaaave a sword.
heh, lemme open up the light again
so hopefully I can see something.
ah.
okay.
So there's something ah
there's something he-
there's something about that
it's a puzzle but it's not
an impossible puzzle it's a puzzle I can
solve. Ah here we go! take it,
ok, (*aha music*) so I got the western s-
...that didn't sound good.
oh no
oh that ain't bad
I got a lot of chills
Oh boy.
so there's an unseen corpsey corpse
oh, now i've got two
swords. ohh,
now they match again. that's
ok, now I've got two swords.
whowoopedyboopedy
Okay, so
I just gotta stab
something in here
hebleedubluh!
Yeah! Suck on that!
Uh oh! Well...
Was that the uh... in here?
How 'bout I turn on the goddamned light again?
Ah! blood on the walls!
"Some things (*laughs*) you're happier not seeing."
Yeah!
Yeah, I guess so!
I don't know what I did but...
boy howdy, I sure did it!
Ewhhh...
I'm gonna go save before something kills me immediately again.
'Cuz that's how this works.
(*save chime*)
Aright...
Now we're gonna find out
what the fuuuuuck it wanted from me
I dunno...
Okay...
Is there something in the fireplace now?
"Floor is gone, revealing the ladder." Okay - descend.
Doooon't!!
Doooon't descend!
Oh there was save here
Mi-ror!
Okay - look in deep into the reflection
and hopefully this is going to give some insight into our back story
because this is the last mirror, I believe
besides that other one in the other room.
(*calm yet ominous background music*)
"You really don't have to see me off."
"It can't hurt to be safe at night, right?
My house isn't far from here either.
Then again, since you're black all over, maybe strangers won't even notice you, Mishiro."
"Why are you so nice?"
"Ehhhewhh?!?"
"I've already served as a model for your sister.
There's no need to f- care about me, is there?"
"Unhh?
I mean, I certainly wasn't deepening our friendship solely to get you to model for me."
"Then what do you want of me? No need to hide it.
You've done a lot for me, Ayato."
"Hold on, what's this all of a sudden?
I don't want anything particular 'out of' you."
"That can't be right. It doesn't make sense.
There can't be any reason why you would approach me without any motive."
"Personally, I don't calculate motives or pros and cons when I'm making friends with people.
Do you, Mishiro?"
"Didn't I tell you? To me interacting with others means getting warnings from my mom and teachers."
"I did hear you were s- in such a situation."
"Then you have already forgotten what it means for people to interact without a reason.
My mom does it to preserve her family's name.
My teachers do it to fulfill their job of teaching.
And so, what is it for you, Ayato? I don't understand."
"You're overthinking it, Mishiro.
I don't meet with you and talk with you for a reason.
I guess, strictly speaking, it's just whether to fi- we find talking to each other pleasant or not.
That's all.
I heard your mom has been disciplining you harshly ever since a few years ago.
And that your high school is very strict all girls school.
But that's irrelevant. Whatever your situation, there's no inherent meaning in people mingling.
I first spoke to you because you resembled my sister
but keeping in touch with you hasn't been for any purpose.
And that's fine. That's how things are. So loosen up, okay?
Besides, you like having someone to talk to, right?
I think of you as a good friend, at least.
I'd be shocked if you didn't think of me about that."
Meabouthaabeeaboume (*Mark trying to correct himself*)
"I didn't mean to say..."
"IIIII'm just kidding.
Really, though, enough of the all overly logical thinking.
Or else my meager dream of seeing you smile might never come to pass.
All right, let's go."
"Um..."
"Hmm."
Th-than.
What?
Uh?
Huh?
(very confused and concerned Markimoo)
(*much glass breakage*)
How'd that happen?!?
I mean, obviously it's hard to portray in RPG maker, but...
Did he throw himself in the way, or us out of the way of it?
"Just stop it."
"Ayato protecting her from the reckless driver headed toward her
and becoming a bloody lump of meat"
Wow, great description (ew).
"Mishiro Usui's heart dying in that instant.
and her loss of hope from losing Ayato carrying her to Mirror Lake
in which she threw herself in despair.
All these things Mishiro remembered.
Just as Mishiro regained a peice of her memory, she felt as if she'd lost something important."
As per usual.
(*save chime*)
Oooohhh boy.
(*footsteps thunk thunk*)
(slightly louder) Ohhh boy!!
(lower) Ohh boy.
(with assertion) Ohhh boy!
(fith time, lower) Ohh boy.
Okay.
(*somber music*)
Well that's all the mirrors for now, except for this one...
(*door closing & plink plink piano*)
And I don't know if I'm going to be able to get to it is the question.
So, let me...
(*door opens*)
.... do this thing....
(long hallway)
Oh, is the only one that you can get to - oh the only one you can get to must be the bottom one, then.
Sorry about that.
Oh, I need to save before I do that.
Oh no - wasn't there a save th - yeah, whatever.
Save here.
(*save chime*)
No harm in it! No harm in saving too much.
Not like I'm gonna go back later in the game and get an alternate re - le- end lending. (laughing)
Right guys? (*giggles*)
Euh..
Alright. So it was this one.
(*continuous somber background piano music*)
was the correct one
then up here....
SHABABOOSKY!
Okay, so down here. Maybe. Just maybe...
this works...
Dammit. "Some requirements need to be met."
This must be a secret ending mirror.
Something that you get... along the way.
This must be an unlockable mirror
like a last step type mirror
And I just haven't done enough, and now there's every possibility that...
you know
there is another ending there, but I don't know if I'm gonna ever get to it.
So, let's get to the "real,"... or not the real
'Cuz there's always like a "true ending" to these games.
But...
Let's get to the uh...
"Standard Ending" first.
Okay. Hello!
"Deep in the realms huh?" Okay.
"Doesn't bother me?"
Yep, I'm remembering myself.
"Now that she's broken all the mirrors, perhaps Mishiro can open this door if she wishes." (*door opening*)
Alright!
(*piano plinks*)
Oh!
Huh?
*reading on-screen text*
Oh, hi, thank you (back to reading text)
Well, I don't know about that!  (back to reading)
Wow! Okay (reading again)
oh geez (reading)
But aren't you dead already?!
Isn't that the thing? that this is kind of like a death world limbo state
WOOOOO UUM
*disagreeing noise*
Those seem like two things
If you grant your wish you don't exist and don't you have to kill Ayato for that to happen
Kind of a cross-roads here
Let's try 'um both, I guess
I'll grant my wish "There's no choice to make. I threw myself in to put an end to it all, and yet I wound up in this world, learning all these unnecessary things, led astray.
I'm just tired. Enough of this.
I've hard enough, so just grant my wishes already."
What?! I didn't want nu- wha- chi- HANG ON!
That's not what I wanted
*on-screen text*
A blank dream.
Technically speaking.
But I don't know if that's very satisfying
Stepping into the
the realm of nothingness from whence you came
and there's still that secret mirror, I don't know how to open it, but
I, the other option seemed oddly familiar to this one because it said 'I'll kill Ayato'
man
How many endings are there? I bet five considering the uh madness one was five and that one was four so it was counting down
well obviously the dead ends are endings to but whatever
okay
so
almost there, don't want to skip past it, BUUUUUUT
okay, aaaaaaand
(singing) yeidiidiidit
di di di dit
di dit deeee (speaking again) there we go
so it's, it's the same thing
right?
*reading text*
well it's the same thing!
(*stabby noise*)
so it's the same thing, that's not even a choice
there's gotta be something else. there, there might be something, maybe I don't have to restart but that last mirror, it's a thing
so i'll be right back
i'll be right back as soon as i figure out what it is and let you guys know about it so be right back
OKAY so I looked up a walk-through and there are actually three more endings
and they involve other mirrors from other people
so if you've noticed these teddy bears
the teddy bears? like the one in the gold room over here?
they, they indicate
other people's mirrors and the locations for them therein so in order for me to get these mirrors
i have to do them in this order. There's Uzu's mirrors, and then there's Riotaro's mirrors
so i believe
Isn't this, aren't those these guys?
It's their mirrors, so it's their mirrors but they're not gonna go in for themselves so I'm just gunna go a' hit 'em one at a time and the first one
'You have to pull the lever by the teddy bear in the realm of beauty' which is one of the bronze doors
The realm of greenery, and the realm of beauty would be across from it
no, no, not that one
maybe the realm of beauty is up here?
Realm of Beauty?
yeah, okay,
so in the, uh, there's a room in here
there's a room in here
oh shit, i forgot about that
MAN, I'm going to go through memory lane with all these so
I'm gunna get back to you as soon as I find them
Ahhhh, okay, so that was what that was and then okay, so
that teddy bear has already been pulled so that goes to the realm of greenery over here, which drops a gate
that leads BACK
oooooverrrrrrrrrr
ooooooover
Aaaahh, see? okay, so they're all combined with these things
OOOOOOO SHIIIT
okay so this is, this is good, so these are their mirrors and these are their stories, so let's go for it
"doesn't seem to change as much as Mishiro looks" okaaay so what do I do about that
*reading text*
okay, so i'm gunna save *save noise* before all this happens and then we're gunna go in there
Here's your mirror! Go do your thing.
*reading text*
AAAhhhhh
OK
8 years ago, a middle school
ooohhh
so we're actually going to learn their story, too
*reading on-screen text*
okay
interesting!
huh
*reading*
Okay
huh!
alrighty then
iiiiiinteresting OH THANK YOU FOR BRINGING ME BACK that makes life so much easier
okay, so the second one requires a silver key
adjust the lantern's light from the realm of death
HAHA!
That's what I just got, so I wouldn't have been able to get any of these if I hadn't already gotten to the near-end of the game okay here we go
*reading*
Ahhhre (are) you know?
These are some pretty philosophical 14 year olds
*reading*
Yeah, no joke! I have no idea
that is
that is an intense... teenager
alright
*reading*
I got a mystery key!
That's good! *reading*
Okay!
Gooooood
Greeaaaaat
I don't know what that means
Okay, so I'm going for ending number 1, which is apparently the best ending
I have to, it, it's convoluted, it says 'view all three of both Yuzu and Riotaro's mirrors, make sure you DO NOT SEE either Tamaki or Rinzu
until you've shown both characters their final mirror.
once both have seen their third mirror, visit both Tamaki and Rinzu
go in to the final door at the end, choose "I won't grant my wish" '
and I don't know
whoooo Tamaki or Rinzu are
it's obviously not these people, cause these are Yuzu and Riotari
But either way, let's go to it, i don't, i don't have time, so
okay, 'ALL of Mishiro's mirrors broke and got the mystery key, go down to the fireplace, matches in the realm of death'
so go to the realm of death and i believe that's this one here
ah, there's a ladder, so there's a ladder here,
and apparently
ahhhh, okay, so this doorway leads to the third mirror
so I need to show them
I need to show the other person
their mirrors too
before I go through that door, so I can't go through that door yet or I may not go through that door at all because that's going to be ending 2
and it said that it locked my into that ending, so I wanna go for ending number 1
At least that's my understanding of it, I'm trying to play it safe here, I don't wanna get locked out of anything
even though I think like the save game system is a little better than that
but I might as well get everyone else THERE
phone call, 5 years ago
I'm calling it, this is either going to be some sort of
either death in the family or something cheating on someone (*begins reading onscreen text*)
Is this just normal conversation in Japan?
If you're not married by 30, you're a pedophile? What?
I must have misunderstood that, because that was weird
*reading*
What?
ooohkay, this is bizarre
very strange
uuuuh
*reading*
WILL DO BUDDY!
You weirdo..
Alright.. So that's another one down..
Gettin through em!
Okay.. Realm Of Blood
Okay here we go
Goooot it
*Reading*
So what do we have?
So not too long ago this time!
Hmm
*Reading*
So this guy's Mishiro's uncle!
If that wasn't obvious enough you guys *wheeze* and all of those ham-fisted "Brother-in-law!" "Like a good uncle!"
This guy is Mishiro's uncle. How strange :D
*reading*
Oki-dokey then!
So-
Okay so if I- if I'm not mistaken I'm-I'm pretty sure this is how that goes.
I need to go through both of their doors with their keys because that's where the last mirror is
And then go through the big door after I've seen both of their doors
It's not gonna
Ahh, it's not gonna, is it?
Okay
Yeah it-it must be!
I-It must be! It must be like a sequence of the two
Yeah!
'Cause the teddybear is there
And then this-
*le gasp*
OOOOH The door BEYOND the mirror!
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOAAAH
I thought- okay that makes a lot more sense
So that door..
BEYOND!!!
Leads to another ending, that's ending one and ending two
And I can just do that
OR
I could go to both of them and not go through that door, and then go through the main door.
Okay so I'm gonna save here..
Separate save file
Totally fine
*reading*
I don't think this is gonna be a good memory!
They never really are if they lead to your death..
Woah
*reading*
That's obsession right there.. That is serious obsession.
Huh
Huh *reading up ahead*
Okay
Welp, lemmie just do this first!
'Cause I believe this is ending one of the endings
SURE WHY NOT! I think..
Why not find out?
*faint piano music*
*reading*
OH GOD *Disgusted Markimoo*
That's not-
WHAT?!
*reading*
Oh it's all coming together
Ah..
Fascinating
*reading*
Mmk hang on..
There's one more thing to do before we go
I might be able to clear everything
There's a ladder in the fireplace! Ahhhh okay!
So this leads to..
Another door.
It wouldn't ever- ohhhh.
OOOOH OKAY
OOOOOOOOHHHH
That's fascinating!
Okay, so now I have load
This one
Okay.
So now-uh-now- but you guys have seen that now and now you guys can connect the dots to that
And that's what it meant by locking you into another ending
Ohh
Ohhhh that's-that's really cool
That is really cool
Okay
So now
I need to take her back and then I need to go up North
To the other one.
And I'm hoping it's not still going to be locked up because
That would be-
I FUCKING FORGOT
I WALKED ALL THAT WAY?
God damnit!
Alright so here we go
*reading*
Okay.. Thanks uncle!
ugh
uh-oh
Well that ain't good!
Alright..
*reading*
Well that was it? Oh.
Okay *slightly confused Markimoo*
Well let's go-uh-let's go ahead to this door. We're going to save right before it obviously and then we're gonna go into the door
And then load up and then go to the
main door after both of these people have been addressed.
Oh boy..
Oh no is this grandpa?? Is this grandpa the creepy??
*reading*
I THINK YA MISSED A FEW STEPS IN BETWEEN THOSE YA FUCKING ASSHOLE!!
Alright whatever
*reading*
Ughh
Welp, similar story but it's like more of a he shed *Markimoo corrects himself* he said, she said thing so it's nice to get both sides of it.
Oh COME ON!! But I thought-
Wait a minute-
OOOH I know- I know what it is. Okay.
AHHHHH
AH AH AH AHHH
Ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
AHHHHHHHH (You okay Markimoo?)
Okay Rinzu and Tamaki- I know what they are!!
Oh that's why the names didn't seem familiar! They're the people in the jail cells!
I can see them BOTH now
AHHHHH That makes so much more sense!!!
I can actually, honestly see them both
Because now..
I've opened the doors to get to them. So I can hear their story
And then
oooooOOOOOHHHHH *Thank you for joining us on another special episode of Markimoo's opera*
Okay I'll be right back.
Ahhhhh
The door opens now. The door opens and we're able to go :D
Oh and the teddybears were pink and blue to signify which was which
Okay!
I got it yeeeaaahh
Okay.
OKAY Argh this is good!
This is good! Okay, so now they're both here!
*reading*
So now, going into this door is going to get the FINAL ENDING!
Oh hai >_>
*reading*
Oh. Me first though!
Oh shit.. Are we doing something?
*reading*
Uh oh.
UH OH
Uh-oh uh-oh uh-oh uh-oh
Wha-
Ohh good thing I got THE MOVES BABY!
Huh-ho!
Yeah okay so this is weird, okay.
*reading*
Goin on 30?!
I'm 27 I BETTER NOT BE THAT OUTTA SHAPE BY NOW!!
Alright.
*reading*
Okay..
*Markimoo noises*
I'm ready!!
Ready for it!
What?
Are we running?
Okay..
Here we gooo!
AAAAahhHH
We're runnin- Oh she's faster this time
Woah-ho good thing she got tripped up
Oh boy
Oh boy- aaAAH
AAAH
*seizes*
AHHHHH AH HA HA
Woah
Got ya!
Oh boy
Alright.
Got that
*reading*
GoooOOOD QUESTION!
Alrighty then
I suppose we go on ahead
Here we go..
LET'S DO THIS
I don't know how this is going to go
Oh boy
Hello.
Hi.
*reading*
Oh hello.
This is the atelier
*reading*
I have a lot of things to say but I'll wait til the end.
Awww what a lovely portrait
Awwwh
Awh
I am so glad I went through the time to get through the whole game and get that ending
That is
Man..
That-That's why I love these RPG m-maker games
Like
Because
Not all, of course, not all. Every game is different.
But for the most part like these games
Like they have heart
And that's what really means a lot to me
Like it has heart, and it has meaning and it has a story that you can
like follow and you know somewhat relate to and you can understand and you can appreciate the story for what it is.
As dark as it gets and as much as this was a horror game,
filled with sometimes cheap jumpscares but good scares,
Like..
What a good game!! What a good game! What a good story!!
Man!
I mean obviously I'm not singin' the praises that it's the best story I've ever heard, I'm not going to be sensationalist like that
But GOD
That was-
Man I can't believe I waited a YEAR for that
I mean there's a lot of sensitive subjects here obviously and
A-a-and thank you everybody for sticking with me for so long
And I know that this is probably coming as a suprise for you guys uh, that this video came at all, but
For those of you who came through it to the end a-a-and were patient with me to get through to it um
Just thank you! You know?
I-I-I-I've been you know, trying to
(Thinking)
*sigh* Stay more consistent and that becomes harder and harder when you try to stretch yourself so thin
But god when I play these games it reminds me of like the old days, and like
Playing just games for playing them
And not that I don't do that anymore, it's just like..
*giggle* It's just one of those things where it makes me think back on all the uh..
All the other games that I played.
And all the other stories that I've- I've gone through with you
You know?
Sharing them with you is an important thing but
Lemmie finish this.
"I've always wanted to go to one of her exhibitions."
"Sure enough. she carries the blood of the mad genius Rinzou Usui..."
"I thought I saw the Rinzou touch too. at first. but she's self taught. It's totally different from Rinzou's art"
"Huh. I suppose so. How unusual. In her twenties. and climbing so high with her own style..."
"She's not just riding off her ancestor. Rinzou was realistic while she's more impressionist."
"That's true. I did feel "Mirror World" was too unusually abstract to be Rinzou's style."
"Seeing is believing. You can tell the unique mood in her art from a glance."
"True. true. Now I'm really getting excited seeing it!" (To see it)
"Her most famous masterpiece of all. Her..."
Blank dream?
Her fantasy, to live in a dream within white canvas
Man..
Ahhh man I love it I love it I love it I love it I love it I love it!
Aw man I love it
Oh man
I mean there's not much else to say than there's been already explained in this story just that I'm very happy
To go through these things with you guys
And I'm happy to share these experiences with you
And you know..
*Sigh*
I'm happy to
Get back and finally finish this game after so long, I've been putting it off for so long..
And I shouldn't have
And you know, I just want to get back to the truth
And get back to the real
And get back to..
The things that matter most, you know?
Well also moving forward, like I can't stop moving forward, but also
Like remembering the cool things...
And looking forward to the even cooler things in the future.
I'm talking very abstract, don-don't read too much into my mad ramblings right now
I'm just trying to voice this weird bubbly feeling of happiness and nostalgia that I got inside of me.
But either way, thank you everybody so much for watching
And thank you for joining me on this epic adventure in Blank Dream
And thank you for those who believed in me
And held onto hope that I would finish this someday
I appreciate every single one of you (awe thanks Markimoo..Luv you)
So thanks again, and as always..
I will see YOU
In the next video!
Bye-bye!